scp-682 versus scp-938  can this electrical entity provide an  adequate shock to 682 system  scp-682 was placed in the containment  chamber attached to site-7 an electric  device was brought into the room and  routed into scp-938  the device increased in electrical  voltage to the point that it damaged  scp-682  causing burns to its body and paralyzing  it for one hour at this point it  regained motion capabilities and shot  electricity from its spine through its  head then it lost consciousness though  it was still breathing and remained that  way for several days as its body  recovered not quite as electrifying as  the foundation had hoped so it appeared  the researcher for this test dr carly  did at least note that electrical or  mine-based scps did tend to keep scp-682  immobilized longer than physical or  chemical attacks